according to a case that was won by
Martin Luther King Jr's family in the
late 90s Hoover's FBI was responsible
for killing Martin Luther King Jr
doing
um yeah I linked to kill Martin Luther
King Jr yeah there was a Civil Trial
that was brought by King's own family
and they said and the result of that was
yeah it was the FBI
Winnie I have a question and that was
the 60s so if nothing happened to them
then what do you think is going on now I
you know my problem is that I feel like
you know thinking about like my own
family for example and how they like
view my work or my grandparents people
like that you know this the way they
were told things worked is not the the
way things were really working then
and a lot of the American public in my
opinion has sort of been fed this fairy
tale that the government is your friend
the government's here to help but
essentially if you look at the history
the government's the mob
or they act like the mob they well
they've it's funny everything that they
arrested the Mobsters for they've been
doing it but it's consolidation you know
what I mean yeah so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]